The Educational Justice
Institute, or TEJI,
provides college-level
courses to incarcerated people
using a mixed classroom model.
Meaning, half of the
students in a given course
will be incarcerated
students, and the other half
will be MIT students.
I mean, by the time you
reach the classroom,
there are probably three
or four locked doors
that you have to go
through to get out.
The mixture of these two
populations in those classes
is really wonderfully
moving and enlightening.
We all learn a lot
from each other.
People from very, very
different backgrounds--
very, very different
life experiences.
These courses will focus
on things like forgiveness,
or anger, or love--
things that we all share.
Marissa has been with
us from the beginning,
from her freshman year, and
she's now a graduate student.
She's in many ways one of
the founders of the program,
because she's always been
completely reliable, and so
hardworking.
I got to hear how
impactful education can
be for incarcerated people.
I still remember on the
first class I ever went to
in a prison, one man told me how
prior to his experience taking
courses in prison,
he had never felt
like anyone had believed in
him before in his entire life.
And this man was
probably in his 40s.
Forming that kind of
connection with people
and seeing yourself really make
a difference in their lives
is just tremendously rewarding.
I think in a few years,
we're going to look back
and we're going to see that
MIT made an enormous difference
in prison education, and
in the culture of prisons
in the state.
And really now
throughout New England
because we're working in Maine
and New Hampshire as well.
If you put together
a community of people
who are passionate about
an issue you can really
make a change, and
in the case of TEJI,
we seem to have the right
skills and resources at MIT
to really make an impact
in this specific way.
Everyone has something
that they can offer,
and it's just a matter
of putting together
the right communities and
connections to make change.